creating his e-commerce app Angela and
Rob start talking business and Angela
promises to help Rob with his app
creation she assures him that she will
look into his business requirements and
coordinate with him to get the app
running Rob is happy about it and
increased to cooperate with Angela
regarding all the business requirements
from his end Angela as we know is the
business analyst she starts planning
Rob's project and without any delay she
embarks on this Project's Journey she
has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill Rob's requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about Angela's approach that helps her
deliver Rob's project smoothly and
without any hassles
the steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these rules
better
first and foremost Angela understands
Rob's business objectives problems and
requirements without understanding this
do you think Angela will be able to
proceed no how it is like Angela
understands the problems related to
Rob's business and comes up with the
right solution to achieve the goals of
the business she brainstorms around what
is presented
Gadgets in The Next Step Angela gathers
all the necessary requirements here she
understands Rob's requirements and makes
sure that they are on the same page
regarding the project and its goals both
of them together arrive at a stipulated
deadline for the project completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
needs to login cost of the products and
style to name a few once Angela has an
in-depth understanding of Rob's project
and gathers all the necessary
requirements she starts allocating
Resources by keeping in mind the budget
of the project I had a conflict she
recognizes and allocates and resources
to the development management studies
please work closely with the developing
team to design the solution for a
problem
ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
Rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
Angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to Rob she continuously
monitors the purpose and constantly
drawings
with respect to the apps layout design
and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application in The Next Step Angela
collects feedback of the Prototype
version of the app from the internet
is validated the project is running fine
with the help
they verify if the solution being worked
on is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
to use expectations
also assessed the functional and
non-functional requirements your
thoughts are collecting feedback Angela
moves to one of the most crucial duties
and that is building reports data
visualization is a key skills in order
to gauge the performance
Angela builds reports of various data
visualization
reports can be General reports such as
detailed reports or it can be dashboard
such as visualized reports with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators it is not
uncommon for issues to profit amidst
this entire process since Angela
conducts regular meetings
and job to solve problems having these
meetings will help understand the status
of the project and it will also help the
teams proceed in the right path
throughout this project phase Angela
makes sure to maintain transference on
completion of the project Angela
documents and presents the project
findings to draw generally business
analysts present the project outcomes
and clients along with maintenance
reports on all the project learnings and
details in a concise manner
take better decisions in the future
will save our time while implementing
the next project now that she has
completed all her duties and
responsibilities with respect to
approach projects she is ready to
deliver the final e-commerce application
to Rob for use Rob is just assured that
the application developed by Angela's
firm is at this business and just what
he wanted
Angela's streamlined approach made it
easier for the project to be delivered
within the stipulated time period Rob is
happy and I'm sure he will come back to
Angela's form for projects in the future
so those responsibilities that we saw
Android carry out are ideally the roles
in responsibilities for any business
analyst out there behind it yes
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you can do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
[Music]
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements deliver data
driven Solutions can generate reports to
Executives and stakeholders business
analyst is an individual who is a part
of the business operation and works
closely with the technology team to
improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions growing a career in a
field with high demand such as business
analysis could be a challenge and
competition for business analyst
positions can be intense so you should
have a clear understanding of the roles
and responsibilities of a business
analyst
um
you should
understand the business problems and
think of a lucrative business solution
Aggregate and automate the process they
need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst up until now from BS interact
with the development team to design the
solution for solving a particular
problem we often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team for spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
creatures need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
because you don't have enough time when
these identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business business analysts run meeting
with stakeholders and other authorities
hence discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products services is software and
Hardware can improve efficiency and add
value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line
they also ensure that the project
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights we
also deliver maintenance reports your
work schedule we need to develop
informative coherent and useful
documents for the success of a project
so let me business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and promote it behind the
problem so let's look at the top skills
to become a successful business analyst
the first skill we have is understanding
the business objectives the delivery
partner that provides for a business
analyst